[Music]
hello youtube chess lovers my friends
this is gunjan here
welcome to my 60th episode of dirty
chess tricks
in today's lecture i am going to show
you some beautiful tricks and traps
in the nimso indian leninguard variation
from the black perspective the opening
arises after the following more order d4
knight to f6 c4 e6
knight to c3 and we have the nimzo
indian on the moon
with bishop to b4
now by far one of the most popular
choice by white
is to play leninguard variation which
start with
bishop to g5
here the main line start with at 6
however in my video i always deliver the
surprise package
and here my recommendation is
you should start with c5
okay white has few options and amongst
them
d5 is one of the main line move
but let's see what happens if white
tries
other moves first of all d capture c4
is a horrible positional blunder because
after bishop capture c3
and the move pawn capture c3 you can see
that
horrible pawns on the c file and it is
just
matter of time as i have highlighted
over here
black can munch those pawns and create
a winning positions
so that is right out of the equation
the second move which i want to consider
is e3
which believe it or not is very famous
especially
in the quick games and surprisingly
as per the online database there are
more than
250 feed a games goes into this
direction
where i'm afraid white's fifth move
is a great time disaster yup
you heard it right because black's next
reply
literally get the winning advantage
queen to a5 and no matter
now however white wriggles it is only
black
who is coming on the top
for example i have even seen the move
bishop captures f6
in my blitz games which is a big time
inaccuracy by white
as after the simple continuation bishop
captures c3
pawn capture c3 queen capture c3
white has to move the king and after
that
yup you simply recapture the piece
and not only black come up with a
complete pawn advantage
but white has a horrible game sitting on
e2
well by far the most popular choice here
is
queen to c2 defending the knight
and now all set to capture on f6
but here black unleash another tactical
idea
and i hope you indeed see it right
yup knight to e4
so not only pressurizing the c3 knight
but the meantime white bishop
also get attacked
well the obvious reason why it cannot
take this knight
because of bishop capture c3
once again you cannot touch that bishop
otherwise the rook in the corner hangs
so white has to play king to d1
but after bishop captures b2 rook to b1
and now the star move c captures d4
forces the more exchanges rook captures
b2
queen captures g5 and after queen
captures d4
once again we have the familiar scenario
where not only black come up with a hole
pawn advantage
but white king is completely misplaced
probably here the most tasting replies
knight g to e2
which at first sight looks very strange
as
you've given up the whole piece but
there is a tactical justification
and you should know this pattern because
after knight captures g5
h4 and white is regaining
the piece back so good try by white
but black is up to the task and he has
the equally strong namely c captures d4
the big point is after e captures d4
black has this winning move on this
position
could you spot it congratulations
if you find the move queen to f5 as
it wins the game on the spot
well now black has multiple thread
including
queen captures f2 and knight capture c3
and in some lines don't forget this
loose bishop
all in all it doesn't matter how waver
wide respond
black get instant winning position
for example in one of my own blitz game
my 2000 rated opponent continue with f3
but this is a huge mistake as after
knight capture c3 attacking the queen
queen captures f5 black has this
wonderful
in-between move knight captures e2 a
discover jack
and after king takes and pawn takes
queen
the dust is clear and black emerge
with the whole piece up
last but not least probably the most
strongest reply here is
knight g to e2 which has a similar
concept
that after black's knight to e4
this time around white wants to play
queen to d3
supporting the c3 knight and if black
now plays
knight captures g5 then h4
will regain the piece back
okay no issues our old friend will join
the party
and if you remember the last trick yup
c captures d4 pawn catches d4
and now very simple transaction
bishop captures c3
well here it doesn't matter how waver
white recaptures
let's say knight capture c3 black has
this
ultimate blow knight catches f2
bam well white response is force
king captures f2 what else but after
queen catches d5
we have the similar scenario pawn up
white king is misplaced and what mode
you can ask
in the opening from the black
perspective
okay so now let's move on to the
business end
where white continue with the main line
d5 grabbing every single space
in the center of the board and we are
going to continue with
d6 kind of
structure pay special attention guys
because you are going to witness one of
the high profile trick
in the main line and as per the database
many many strong players has fallen into
well for the few moves both the side
follow the main line
white plays e3 liberating the white
square bishop
we are going to chop on d5 and after c
captures d5 the very cunning move
which sets up the tricky platform and
that is
knight b to d7
so the idea is very obvious as we have
provided the support to the f6 knight
our queen can literally leap in
on the a5 square
okay by far here the main move is
bishop to d3 so white remain flexible
as per the requirement the g knight can
either come to f3 or e2
and then white wants to castle with the
space in the center
and yes indeed that all looks good
except
one problem that black has this obvious
moon
queen to e5 which ruin all the white
form
okay white has to defend this knight so
knight g to e2
and now you will see the whole point
behind the move queen to e5 because
after knight captures d5 we are going to
open up the fifth rank and
although black has one upon here this is
irrelevant
because his d6 pawn is weak
but as the game progresses you will see
what is the big idea of the black cat
the best move in this position is to
castle on the king side
and after that we are going to capture
on c3
with our bishop now
the natural move in this position knight
captures c3
completely fails due to this simple
fifth ring tactic
and i hope you indeed spot it instantly
knight capture c3 pawn capture c3
and now c4 and
white lose a piece
so knight capture c3 is right out of the
equation
that means white is forced to capture
with the pawn
and after that another star move comes
into the picture
c4 once again
the opening of the fifth rank and
white should not take the spawn in the
view of
yup you got it knight to b6
once again winning the piece
so that means after c4 white bishop has
to move
and the most popular choice here is
bishop to c2
after that rather than capturing on c3
my recommendation here is you should
castle first
safe on your king and now all set
to launch the devastation
well there is a discover attack on the
white bishop
so white has to save the bishop first
with
bishop to h4 but that leads to
this very simple sequence knight capture
c3
knight capture c3 queen capture c3
still white cannot get d6 because his c2
bishop hangs
but okay white has some initiative with
rook to steven trying to get a mcqueen
queen to e5 bishop to g3
we are more than happy to sacrifice our
backward pawn
with queen to e5 and after
bishop captures d6 rook to e8
the dust has been settled down and
one can easily see that not only
black emerge with a clear pawn advantage
but once his two minor pieces comes out
then white is literally struggling
for any compensation
just to show you how easy this position
is for the black
one of the high profile game continue
with
bishop to b1 not only defending
on a2 but attacking on c4
and in the future white has some ideas
of queen to c2
guess what black response is very
obvious
knight to b6 defending on c4
if queen to c2 then g6 is a very strong
reply
so i'd continue with e4
but after that last piece comes out
with ease bishop to v6
connecting the rogue and in fact
later on this extra pawn do
create problems for the white and black
managed to get
a great victory you can check the rest
of the game in the pgn
but at this position it is easy to say
that black is in a complete
driving seat with the extra pawn
that's it guys i hope you enjoy and
learn this
high profile tricks in the nimzo
leninguard variation
you can literally use this line in the
tuna in practice
as a complete surprise weapon and get
the win
very very quickly well thank you for
watching this video
feel free to like subscribe and comment
and i will meet you
in my next episode very soon bye
and take care